[Music]
welcome to the global progressive forum
progressive leaders and thinkers from
around the world are setting out their
vision for a sustainable and equitable
decade for the future we can talk about
that in our discussion here today
because if you're not engaging then no
one's listening and i think that the
onus is on us today in this conference
to talk to people in a way that will
actually cut through the blah blah blah
as someone very famous recently said
you just came out of a negotiation what
was it on today we were talking about
the very relevant a privacy regulation
meaning protecting confidentiality of
all our communications
and we made some first progress but the
most important elements are still in
front of us okay so there's a road ahead
but you're on a good path
i hope so
so you will be telling us how uh people
can follow us on social media how to
comment how to get involved correct
exactly so you can comment you can react
on twitter using the hashtag gpf2021
and you can also participate to our poll
on the globalprogressiveforum.org
website i'm going to head back now to
the main studio so please ladies can you
hear me take it away are you worried
about governments having your data or
companies a little bit of both more
worried about my mom seeing my having my
data but
that is my privilege
to tell you that myrtlevitboy
is the winner
of this special award she has been spare
heading the fight against injustice and
the neglect of domestic workers in south
africa and far beyond over 100 million
people are already being pushed into
extreme poverty our job as policy makers
is to make sure
that inequality at birth
does not mean a lifetime of inequality
the society as a whole
has to take care of those that might be
left behind
this cannot be a society for a few we
are already seeing that happening too
much
those billionaires that accumulates a
huge part of the wealth of the world
that can cannot continue access to water
is a fundamental human right but there
are lots of communities in southeast
asia where you will not be able to get
water because water is privatized i
don't think we pay enough attention to
how much we have destroyed and degraded
uh water resources and what that means
for the ordinary lives of people
women have to walk double the amount of
time sometimes as much as eight hours a
day to collect water in some parts of
india we must stop that i'm not saying
tone it down we must stop it the
democratic space around the world is
shrinking slavery is back and we from
the unassuming consumer to the brands
fashion brands solar industry um cotton
tomato all the industries are implicated
in this we cannot have like different
kinds sets of standards when a country
is smaller and then when the country
isn't powerful it depends on us
legislators to make it a safe space and
to make sure that no one on this earth
is too big to be regulated when trump
was the president
he used to support dictators
in the arab world so
at that moment we didn't have any hope
that he would put pressure to release
the activists or human rights defenders
in these countries
do we think
that democracy can be regained in in
poland and in hungary and if so how
empowering people empowering
participatory democracy empowering
civil society organizations empowering
those that are
pushing forward a progressive agenda
across the world is the only way we have
a thing to bring positive change
democracy
democracy
conformity
the relationship between china and the
u.s is important for the whole world so
it's a good news that they have found an
agreement on this and the second
aspect of course is the freedom of media
which is under high pressure all over
the world the first point
is to be united
among europeans
if we are not united among europeans it
will be impossible
to
reply to the challenges
of people like putin and erdogan i am
known as multilateral madeleine um i
really do believe that multipleism
given the issues that are out there is
absolutely essential uh and that we need
to work together i do have to say though
that people question what
multilateralism is about
but americans are distrustful of the
word multilateralism it has too many
syllables and it ends in an ism
by 2030 seven of the world's 10 largest
economies will be located in today's
emerging markets when we talk about
growth and the importance of growth it's
also important to ask what is growing if
what is growing is actually inequality
then for most people the situation will
be getting worse
in paradise
just give this money to the
multinational companies and just to
enrich and increase their profits this
time we need to make sure that this
money is invested to create quality jobs
everywhere ensure that
fundamental labor and human rights
standards are included in all trade
agreements you have a few uh pictures
that illustrate the last year we've all
passed
here we have a picture of the world
leaders meeting on zoom
um this was uh yeah also one of the
symbols of the of of the pandemic uh
people paying tribute to healthcare
workers here
uh maybe one of the positive aspects of
the pandemic of the lockdown
which was on the environment we have to
increase our preparedness
for the pandemics
because
this one will not be the last one
progressives need to come together to
argue for
vaccine equity make the covet vaccine
available to every person in every
country by the end of 2022. this corona
crisis is really the crisis with the
face of a woman maybe the most important
bottom line from kovid is that the state
matters the state can and needs to
take care of its people we are great so
far in europe in proposing these laws
and passing these laws partly but we're
terrible at enforcing them if you look
for example the biggest rate or the most
relevant regulator in europe is is the
irish data protection commissioner they
have about ten thousand cases a year and
make six or seven decisions a year so
you have a 99.999
likeliness that your fundamental right
to privacy is just going to trash
everything that brings progress in terms
of technology brings also risks and
that's why
we have
basic principles to stick to
and if we don't stick to them then we
will end up in this chinese world the
chinese government have put in place a
mass surveillance network and that means
if you go into the gas station too many
times in a day you're flagged to the
police
if you use too much electricity you
reflect to the police
if you have donated to the mosque in the
past if you use whatsapp if you have a
connection in turkey in afghanistan if
you call someone there the police will
come and interrogate you and some of
these people end up in political
education camps it's not science fiction
it's happening right now it's super hard
for the authorities to go into every
cell phone of the world but it's rather
easy to go into apple and google and
then be in every cell phone in the world
[Music]
people have a tendency of clustering
themselves in us versus them out of fear
it's very difficult for them to
understand that
in this world there's no other people
who are different i suppose it's out of
ignorance in germany we have a saying
like what the farmer doesn't know he
doesn't eat
the younger generation faces
extreme problems with online hate speech
socially you're not allowed to say the
n-word it doesn't mean that people don't
believe that i'm an n-word when i walk
into a room you need to get in a room
with other white people and ask them why
they've done nothing
apart from going to a couple of black
lives matter marches last year they may
have spoken to some roma people and they
may have one gay friend that they like
outside of that nothing changes
we can't leave the problem of racism and
the problems of homophobia and
transphobia in the hands of the victims
you can't put that at the door of the
victims all of us including
whether black lives matter movement or
the lgbt community we all need to come
together
we all need to resist and be the voice
for
everybody the line has been crossed so
let me show you and let me get some
guidance you know wonderful can we show
for everyone uh what it what it is
actually why don't we put it um i really
hope that you can you can see it the
line has been crossed it's about women
being in solidarity together and taking
men
feminist men on board as well in order
to push gender equality i'd like to
remind the women watching that the the
sign on social media
that has started trending uh to be able
to um
to notify someone if you're in need is
this
82.4 million people worldwide are
forcibly displaced
data from unhcr the un refugee agency
shows that the numbers have doubled over
the last decade there's a lost
generation my brother is one of them my
brothers is eight years old all he has
seen from his life is war there are
millions and millions of syrians who
have again seen nothing but war and
education has been
i mean
taking classes at a at a refugee camp i
don't i wouldn't consider this an
education nobody like to leave his
country the choice isn't hard you can't
it's not a difficult choice when you you
have to choose between letting people
die or letting them survive i am ready
for you and my speakers are ready for
you a very interesting conversation
we're gonna have today about the need
for climate justice this is about the
missions but it's also about money and
for sure it's about reparation of all
the damage that we have caused all
across the world and how to make sure
that we compensate for that when we talk
about moving forward into a more
sustainable economy so we're going to
have representatives from different
parts of the world from the cv society
but also from the political sphere and
we're going to be addressing all those
issues in a minute let's have a
conversation of grown-ups now let's have
a conversation of equals rather than the
european union looking down at all of us
as we were natives and peter turnbuck
post a tweet and she says we ask the
leaders to take decision but if you ask
you will never get anything you must do
much more than ask you must connect this
to politics and say yes there is
difference between conservative politics
and progressive politics football and
sports can
actually make a huge difference billion
people across the globe
football has a unique possibility in
taking a leading role
join us in this vital game
let's play to save the planet climate
change is real so something should be
done you pay taxes on bikes but not on
flights i use the public transfer just
cycling there are two concepts of
politics
the one is solving problems delivering
answers on the questions of our society
and the other one is simply about brutal
power new times demand for new faces i
guess and new methods new politics means
that we see the world in a new
perspective and we start to tackle the
elephants in the room politics is has
already entered a new era where where
people and politicians
can use and have to use social media in
order to communicate with everybody this
is alexandra casacortes it was her
before the met gala so you can see her
and
her designer who has designed the dress
the dress says text the richness it
doesn't take a genius to figure out that
no one country can do it alone
progressive around the world face
similar challenges this is why the
global progressive forum represents an
extraordinary platform to reach common
solutions to global challenges
my hope and dream for the next 10 years
is not just to resolve these individual
issues because they will keep coming at
us
but instead that we have stronger
multilateral institutions that we have
more ways that we can share our global
progressive ideas and values and that we
keep appreciating and understanding the
impact that we have not as individuals
but on one another
that's
my dream and hope for the future a safer
world when it comes to climate change is
a safer world where we can make sure
that people can go to school that they
can have a job where they get salaries
they can live by and and they can make
sure that they can come to the doctor if
they need to you know a real good life
for every citizen globally that is my
dream
come on
[Music]
the dream is never only a dream it is
the first step into a better future
let's never give up because maybe it
takes time to get a change but it's
always worth to go in that direction so
thanks a lot for the opportunity
for
inviting pies
[Music]